far that you know what no just just
watch what has happened in this case so
far um Alvin Bragg dumped this case he
didn't pursue this case okay now maybe
we're figuring out why maybe Alvin Bragg
understood that the statute of
limitations wasn't going to hold up in
this case but no the woman who is in
front of the video do you want me to get
him do you want me to get him I'll go
get Donald Trump she went you know guns
of Blazing forward with this case and
now she has been embarrassed by this
judge who would love to get this guy
right but he looks at the case and says
oh my gosh why did you bring this to me
you've got about 80% of this that
doesn't even hold up in the statute of
limitations on top of that so they are
so Overexposed right between brag and
how he handled it and then Leticia James
and now this judge they all look it's
embarrassing for all of them at this
point right the other side of this is
show me the bank that has been wronged
deceived there's there isn't one there's
no injured party in this case so did
they bring these kind of similar cases
against other real estate developers in
the city I'm not saying it's right to
overvalue your property but the bottom
it the the rubber hits the road when the
valuators from the insurance company and
the bank look at it if you say this
property is worth $80 million they go
sorry it's not they have teams of
valuation people at Banks and insurance
companies nobody is UN not understanding
how much these properties are worth this
there's a lot of cases that are up he
has 91 counts criminal counts okay this
one is is BL going up in their face and
I think it's going to be an
embarrassment and there was a massive
disclaimer also on their assessment
saying you decide what it's worth that's
right yep all right hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now